alright guys bangbang
I have Balaji here with me thank you so
much for doing this um mom super excited
to talk to you
cool good to be here for sure for those
that don't know who you are you've got a
lot of relevant experience and I know
that you are not a fan of credentialism
but they just give us a couple of data
points just on your background and
training so that people can understand
the perspective you're coming from sure
so my background you know Stanford PhD
in electrical engineering also have an
MS in chemical engineering
I taught computer science and stats
Stanford for several years started a
genomics company which have a CTO and
co-founder that ended up that kind of
being sold for three hundred seventy
five million i was angel investor in
soil and superhuman land school Kameo
Bitcoin early in theory m/c cash other
kinds of things also it was a venture
capitalist interested Horowitz
multi-billion dollar venture capital
firm helped boot up what became parts of
our bio and crypto funds I taught a MOOC
course with 250,000 students worldwide
back in 2013 so you know in an educator
as well
and then within crypto I did done a
bunch of stuff I'm an investor in lots
of crypto companies and coins and
whatever but most recently I took over
one of our portfolio companies long
story which I wrote about I've turned
that around turned into earn comm got
that to profitability so let's go in
base with CTF coinbase while a coin base
did a bunch of stuff but in particular
you know one a few headlines to earn and
integrate into coin basic wing base earn
which has done several hundred million
dollars in sales from 2018-2019 you can
it's on the homepage accordingly so if
you if you tried it right so and help
launch us TC
are stable coin which has done very well
drove all the asset addition and so on
there all this is obviously with the
team
folks and without brought on billions of
dollars in assets for custody and and
basically just did a bunch of stuff
there and then since last June I've
finally taken the first time off that
I've had in more than ten years or
whatever and because that you know I
can't like I'm not wired like a normal
person to take a vacation just because
there's you're either doing something
you're not doing it and if you're not
doing it it's much easier then you don't
have it's like a homework assignment or
whatever when you're a kid and you have
something do on a Christmas break and
you know so I can never take like a
normal vacation but took time off first
time in a long time and basically just
you know did math I do math and I
program and I angel invest and whatnot
and that brings us to the present day
you know and I know I can take from here
for sure before we get into the fun
stuff what's the biggest surprise or
learning you've had from taking time off
with the thing you didn't expect to walk
away with or learn during that time um I
think I was surprised at how easy it is
to like like the time passes fast
actually you you wouldn't kind of think
that so yeah I just it's it's uh it's
like a learning or anything like that
but rather unless you go after things
with the same discipline that you have
when you're an operating executive it's
easy to just lose a week lose two weeks
or whatever which is fine you don't
always have to be super efficient on
everything but that was just something
which I hadn't had time off in such a
long time that I hadn't realized that
yeah that's awesome you were one of very
few
early on that identified the potential
issues with the coronavirus and we're
quite vocal about hey this is serious
this may come here here's potential
implications and you know frankly we all
now know many people one laughed to
literally disagree publicly there's
articles written in kind of the whole
nine yards you've been vindicated kind
of in a weird way of nobody wanted this
to happen
but but at the same time you were able
to to kind of warn people if you will
what is your evaluation as we sit here
kind of mid-may of just what's
transpired right we want to go in tons
of detail you know people obviously know
a lot of this but but just kind of
what's your general evaluation of that
health crisis so you know I've treated
some of this and I'm writing a bunch of
long-form stuff for tribal which I will
drop at some point but act one was and
is the virus crisis which is ongoing Act
two is the financial crash and Act three
I think is a crisis of our institutions
and I really think that we are in for
some crazy stuff and I you know I think
I called some of these aspects actually
pretty early on but I think the new
political axis or you know whether you
want to call it trade-off axis or
what-have-you will worldwide is you know
antivirus and pro-freedom okay so those
are like kind of like the two polls you
might call it the total state versus
market anarchy okay
and the so what's what's kind of going
on here so we're in the middle of this
huge political realignment where old
issues just don't matter as much
and things are rotating and new
coalition's are forming even if there's
some old party labels or things like
that and I think you can identify those
two camps as centralization versus
decentralization as modern monetary
theory versus BTC as you know the the
state versus the network as you know
kind of mandatory versus free and you
know health versus wealth okay so it's
actually interesting to think of those
as kind of opposite poles in the sense
that the state is you know the actor
that is now pushing quarantine xand it's
you know it's enforcing stay-at-home
orders
you know masks being mandatory all the
type of stuff and there's a genuine
argument for it in the sense that you
know many many predispositions or
presuppositions rather that people have
about okay you know my neighbor can do
their thing and it doesn't matter so
long as it doesn't affect me completely
break down in a coronavirus world where
if your neighbor is not taking
precautions your variable could get sick
and so you have an interest in their
health in a way that you just didn't
before now in a sense arguably that's
good because you know okay well I have
an interest in their health I will help
them stay healthier and keep myself
healthier at the same time there's you
can make an argument from a skin in the
game or a lineman standpoint that you
know community people who care about
each other's health will probably be
better you know just like you know
you're part of a fitness club or
whatever you know and and you know
people lift together and that's actually
good right so but let's call this one
axis right the total state and that's
you know the lockdown of Wuhan that is
the you know surveillance of folks who
you know with yellow and green and red
codes not just in China but other places
that's price controls etc okay now on
the other side is market anarchy and
this is essentially the polar opposite
of that and this is to caricature in
extremis it is you know don't wear a
mask but or I should have the choice as
to whether to wear a mask it is you know
like the laws are necessarily bad
everything the state is doing is wrong
etc and you know in and but the good
aspect of it is look we're gonna need to
decentralize we're going to need to
encrypt we're going to need to protect
privacy and we're going to need to have
a free market because the state may
protect health at the expense of wealth
to such an extent that folks are giving
silly orders you know to seize masks
seize hand sanitiser
to impose price controls to ban people
from selling things at Walmart
target to stop uber eats from doing
things you know as well as weren't even
proposed like banning em and A's or
whatever over a certain size those
things have nothing to do with
controlling the virus whatsoever and
they're things and of course printing
trillions of dollars right um and so
there's legitimate abuses and failures
on the side of the total state that the
kind of Anarchy pole will little correct
and push against and I think either of
these two poles is probably bad but
what's it and that probably is bad
what's interesting is how many different
permutations and so on there are in the
center it's like a very you know there's
there's a number of different
combinations and things you can do okay
and I'll give some of them so lots of
many different countries it's almost
like the ideologies that they had almost
didn't matter and now they've just
executed in totally different ways for
example Sweden and New Zealand you would
have clustered them together
ideologically before this but they've
taken polar opposite policies you know
where Sweden has basically taken the let
it rip policy and New Zealand has
controlled a virus you know the u.s. in
Australia you might have clustered them
and Australia's contain the virus and
the u.s. is you know not right but then
even more than that you know to give
some sense of where society ends up
you could have a Chinese authoritarian
state you could have a Taiwanese
democratic state that didn't even have a
lockdown but is managed to mostly keep
the virus under control or actually not
mostly seemingly totally you could have
you know a New Zealand policy which is
democratic but also did a lockdown and
got the virus under control
you could have Sweden's policy which had
no lockdown and is letting the virus go
crazy or he could have America's policy
which is kind of a cargo called half
half-assed lockdown
and then combined with letting the virus
corral so it's like at least five
different combinations you know Taiwan
China New Zealand the US and Sweden and
then there's a sixth which I think is
emerging in the u.s. which is the snow
crash strategy and I think this is
actually
where the u.s. is probably going to land
up where some combination of snow crash
and ready player one the state has
failed it is actually not capable of
doing the blocking and tackling if it
had any you know tricks up its sleeve we
would have seen them already at this
point right um there's no crack military
unit there's no you know Special Forces
or you know super vaccine there's
nothing like that there's no area 51
there's no Manhattan Project no one's
coming to save us
um and so once you realize that that's
actually it's something where it's
completely the opposite of the movies
you know in contagion or in you know any
movie you know there's a I mean that's
the biggest thing that contagion the
movie got wrong with the CDC it was
going to be competent right and I'm not
saying the CDC is completely incompetent
that they have something done some
things right you know some of the
studies you've done are fine but they
are not actually able to control a
disease and there's the Center for
Disease Control right so where I think
we land up is some combination and I'm
not endorsing this by the way but I
think you know there's a few possible
scenarios where the US lands up so one
is and these are not mutually exclusive
but let's call it Snow Crash ready
player one and then someone else
actually said ask mobs like naked Sun or
the Salaria is also another one right
but let me go through these so Snow
Crash should basically be where the
state can't protect people you know for
example Amazon is doing like mass
testing of all its employees it's
developing all these technologies to
essentially turn Amazon's camp this into
a green zone and potentially that
becomes an export where they can export
that to other corporate campuses and
other communities you know it's like the
natural extension of raying and some of
the other products that they sell right
where you you basically keep the virus
out with multiple layers of defense for
everything you know the most extreme
would be like negative pressure air
rooms but hand sanitizer gloves all the
type stuff then you know so so basically
what that is is as a corporate
individual and community imposed order
that control
virus and keeps it out out of your
campus but you know the Commons are our
tragedy okay
then second is ready player one where
there's proposal serious proposals to
print two thousand dollars a month for
everybody if you've seen that right and
if that proposal goes through and I
think it might you have a scenario where
everybody is sitting at home and they're
receiving two thousand dollars a month
and that's money which see the thing is
I think we're gonna see both deflation
and inflation deflation in the price of
all the things that people don't want
anymore like like you know air travel or
well actually
air travel is tricky I'll come back to
that let's say concerts events
things of that nature right people will
slash prices to try to bring folks in
but then you look at price inflation and
things people do want like masks hand
sanitizer other type of things right and
once you get soaring prices here's where
the crypto stuff comes in or one of the
many angles
you have soaring prices for masks for
hand sanitizer and you know pulse
oximeters all the type of stuff to deal
the disease as well as for things like
food consumer staples because you've
suddenly injected a huge amount of
printed money and capacity supply is
usually flat or down because people are
staying at home because supply chains
have being disrupted because folks
overseas aren't shipping as much stuff
and so on so you have like much more
money and flat or down supply well and
and you know you have demand right
prices are gonna increase which we've
seen you know fur masks enhance Santa's
right so then once you have prices soar
many states will impose price controls
which will cause shortages and or they
will prevent the sale of some of these
things in eBay and other places I've
actually already prevented the sale I
believe of masks and hand sanitizer and
and again and I'm using as a placeholder
for a lot of other things that people
would buy at which point markets go dark
and you start to get the crypto economy
you know things like open Bazaar and so
on become important because you can't
buy the stuff on an above-ground market
like a mask or whatever is like hard
five masks and you know you can make the
argument like people shouldn't be able
to buy those masks it's only by a
surgical mask or every I understand
right but the demand will be there that
people will want to buy those things
they'll want to buy food and they'll
want to buy consumer staples and whatnot
and so you know essentially this printed
money that they get will be I think
useful for three things you know one
maybe it'll pay the rent maybe there'll
be some price control imposed on the
rent or something like that - maybe
it'll buy food and three it'll pay for
internet stuff which is probably the
most you know like something like
Dropbox is probably gonna have the least
problem when you know there's if there's
significant inflation because their
margins their gross margins are so high
that the marginal cost of delivering
another you know Dropbox thing to
somebody is not not that high right but
then you have this ready player one
world where people are basically staying
home and being paid to play video games
or just surf the internet right and they
just don't go out but consumption is
dropped off a cliff and then the third
model is this naked son model where you
know folks go out to rural areas and
work remote from there and they kind of
have a natural social distancing built
into it
and you know they just socialize over
the internet for the most part other
than being with you know like obviously
they're probably with family members
maybe there's some friends who move out
there but it's like more like a rural
life like a lot of people used to live
in the eighteen hundreds in the US you
know you're just relatively low
population density and you you know
maybe you put on your VR headset or you
you otherwise connect that way but you
have just you know greenery and so on
around it's kind of a beautiful
landscape right um
so I'm not saying all of those I mean
those are not mutually exclusive all of
those could happen at the same time but
we start to get a future that in the
u.s. it looks very different than what
is happening in green zones that have
managed to keep the virus under control
well anyway let me pause here because I
that was a long kind of burst but but I
want you to get Norden god no I I think
keep going the the big thing that I
would just
if you can clarify so I think part of
what you're talking about is like a
decentralized response and then the
state response right those two things
are somewhat counterbalance to each
other but it's not also I don't believe
you think that it's a complete blanket
in even a country right so right now I
think most people would say hey the East
has been very very good from a
centralized standpoint and part of that
is because the population buys into
those centralized governments here in
the West there's a little bit less of
that kind of buy-in and so people are
maybe somewhat wary and also kind of
have this democratic view of like the
government is one voice but we also have
a voice and so that has been somewhat of
a more decentralized response I've seen
you talk a lot though like it isn't just
country by country you actually may get
a break down even further than that yeah
at the state county you maybe even the
city level so kind of keep going on that
thread but just totally yeah yeah sure
should address those funds yeah so so
one very important high-level thing I
think is so two important hi lot of
things in my personal preference stack
rank and other people may differ on this
but at least I think I am consistent you
know or or what I see is consistent
given this implicit value set right
which is more not even implicit I'm
being very explicit about it which is I
would rank like a competent centralized
state like Singapore I think that
delivers the best quality of life I know
Singapore is trying to get you know
corona under control and so on but a
Singapore Taiwan a South Korea and now
discuss my second point and New Zealand
in Australia right they have managed to
get the virus on control so it appears
so Slovakia I think Estonia has I think
Israel has right these are places which
you know I think will provide those are
like that's the best answer like a
competent centralized state for
something like this then a distant
second is the decentralized response the
snow crash response where in the absence
of a competent centralized state if you
have an incompetent or even worse a
malicious state the decentralized
response at least allows you your
community your company to get together
right if you have a hapless government
um what what's happened is the
government is now by not doing a good
job of keeping the Commons free of this
virus it's like a tax on every
transaction that's happening it's
basically like an out-of-control fire
that's burning because the fire
department can't put it out because the
CDC can't control disease because the
FDA hasn't approved tests we have this
viral fire burning that has imposed
attacks in every transaction right okay
so at least allow individuals to put out
the fire in their own little zones
that's a decentralized response and the
worst is like the incompetent or
malicious and you know you can always
argue which which is which but I do
think there's a distinction
you know malicious is like you know
North Korea right or something like that
and you know incompetent is simply just
much of much of the u.s. unfortunately
right and frankly the UK France Italy
Spain even Germany right basically
Western Europe the US and Canada have
actually had some of the worst responses
to this which I can get into and and so
when you've got an incompetent
centralised state they're doing things
like infinite lockdown with no plan
right and that's not that's that's also
that's stupid right like one way of
thinking about it is every country that
is doing lockdown whether they admit it
or not is copying China because China
did it first and was like oh my god I
can't believe they're doing this and you
know at first there was a lot of oh they
would only do this in autocratic and you
know crazy Society etc then people
basically ignored the virus while it was
spreading through China and then Iran it
was only when it hit Italy that that
actually people are like wow you know
like it could actually hit here not in a
third-world country and I'll come back
to that point by the way China is not a
third world country that's well I think
one of the biggest issues that people
you know in the u.s. especially I think
on the East Coast um had is they still
have a time work model of China from
like the 70s as you know primitive
country or oh it only happened over
there you know blah blah blah and it's
it's simply not right it's a very
sophisticated place in many ways
I'm not saying it's all good but I'm
just saying to appreciate that um anyway
once it hit Italy and Italy went into
lockdown
then in mid-march the US copied Italy
and so you're copying a copy without
admitting you're copying and whenever
that happens I mean you being not being
you you're in tech right like as a
product manager if you're copying a
feature from another company without
admitting you're copying that feature ah
you get like a Zune kind of experience
remember the Zune versus the iPod right
or you get like just I mean early Bing
Bing is actually okay today but like
Bing versus Google you're just just
having an ersatz
you know version of the same right and
you know one mental model is you have
this you have this very agile state uh
you know that is able to execute this
kind of lockdown and then you have this
lumbering American you know or westerner
who tries to follow the same gymnastics
and simply can't do it right and so it
might you know when you're talking about
like how the Chinese executed lockdown
or how you know it's being executed in
other places um it's not just Oh
everybody go stay at home it's like a
hundred things they were doing for
example you know centralized quarantine
right they set up these field hospitals
but you know they built these things in
in you know ten days and the hospital
they built in ten days wasn't like the
thing in the Javits Center it was a
hospital that had negative pressure
rooms I mean the Javits Center I mean
look it's fine that they built it I'm
not taking anything away from it but the
lie shanshan hospital those built in
China had negative pressure rooms it had
telemedicine for doctors to come in
remotely it had drone delivery BOTS um
and it was basically set up so that you
could remote operate the hospital and
and the patients weren't you know
exposing like doctors to the virus
because healthcare workers were dying
over there right um you know it was it
was stuff like you know drones with
thermal-imaging cameras it's it's stuff
like you know
mobile CT scanners that are very high
throughput that can just scan a bunch of
folks it's simply a technological feat
where all the levers of both technology
and policy were applied at the same time
I wrote a blog post on this by the way
you know I treated it like you know a
piece of it was you know Chinese
government's guide to containing the
viruses like in v7 and again to be clear
I'm not saying you know Oh China is good
and moral or anything like that I am
saying that insofar as you're copying a
copy you should at least understand what
it is you're copying and what is you're
doing and what happened was in in China
the lockdown was executed and I've
tweeted about this also you could see my
tweets in March on this but in China the
lockdown was a top-down thing that was
executed by the technocrats running the
Chinese state you know in in the US
lockdown was like a bottom-up cry from
Twitter you know from like all these
academics or engineers or whatever like
Tomas poyo like you know I wrote a great
article like this hammer and dance
he's like a random guy right and he's
fine he's smart right like I'm like I'm
glad you wrote the article and so on but
this is something where it's rear-wheel
drive the smart people are not in our
press and state you know these people
literally can't divide you know like I
don't know if you saw that that thing
where you know like everyone blew
Bloomberg could give everybody a million
dollars to the US it's true and Brian
Williams nods at this right like like
you know and obviously our you know
whether it's the mayor or the governor
or the president like these these folks
are not like do not do a great job right
and so you have something where it's not
just the idea it's execution right and
ID Rizzo have people see at home and
then execute all these complicated
series of steps to control the virus
well you know we we simply don't have
the talent in our state to do that and
so so that's a huge divergence and a
branch point especially relative to the
past
because you know 1950 1968 you know the
US - depalo
right within the living memory basically
about 52 years ago right the US was
number one right it could do things that
nobody else could do it was the best at
coordinating huge projects right it
could bring men material everything
together to get things done right and
what's happened is that the state
capacity of the US since since basically
the you know like Apollo project has
just fallen off a cliff and the state
capacity of China and actually India and
other countries has risen over that
period and now there's like a crossing
point right you know there's just no way
that China and 1968 would have out
executed America 1968 but China 2020 has
out executed America 2020 as has frankly
Taiwan and New Zealand and Australia and
Slovakia and Vietnam and and and all
these other countries is a website
called n coronavirus org front slash
countries that goes into this right and
so like it's really important to to
recognize that in the same way that it
was important for for example Steve
Ballmer to understand that Google it out
executed them before you can actually
you know that Apple it out executed them
right like you know he was famously in
in denial about this for a long time you
know and there'd be this sort of
corporate nationalism you know that
happened in Microsoft where he'd say oh
you know I I tell my kids you don't you
don't use an iPhone and you don't use
Google and it's a great way of basically
blinding yourself to what's happening in
the rest of you know the industry again
not saying that you copy it directly and
naively I am saying that you understand
when someone's ahead of you and what
they're doing and and you if you decide
to clone it or you build something
better fine but don't don't be in denial
about it right um another example of
this tweeted was you know with Yeltsin
you know in the late 80s came to the US
right so this was around the time of the
thawing of
US and Russian relations right after
towards the end of the Cold War and
Yeltsin came and he visited and he saw
like a NASA control panel or whatever
right and you know he was like we've got
Rockets in in the Soviet Union as well
not a big deal but I read but you know
what he was really impressed by was that
it was there was a random stop that they
made on the trip home to a supermarket
and when he saw like this brand old
supermarket ok Randall's was just the
name of the chain
he was awestruck there's a famous photo
of him like just holding up his hands
and dismay and basically he's like
because the thing is that an American
supermarket had so much plenty relative
to the drab Russian supermarkets and at
first he thought this was some special
showroom supermarket and a fake one that
you know he'd been brought to because
that's what the Soviet Union did it
faked everything right he's like you
know this is fake or whatever and then
once he realized it was real he realized
that even the leaders of the Soviet
Union of which he was one right he was a
very exceptional person who was allowed
during the time of the USSR to travel
abroad not just anywhere but to America
right so even the leaders of the Soviet
Union had fallen for their own
propaganda about how you know the
capitalist West was was behind and and
and so on and so forth and the leaders
of the Soviet Union didn't have the
quality of this market experience that a
random working person in in Texas would
have had right uh and so he said you
know look if people at home knew about
this there'd be a revolution right and
so you know this is something where it's
so so so important to not have
excessively nationalistic or corporate
nationalism or whatever nationalist
blinders on you know I'll give a third
example what the Meiji Revolution was I
do not ok so um that's how Japan
modernized in the mid-1800s you know
they'd be an isolated Society for a long
time and to shorten a longer story in
the mid eighteen hundreds they came into
contact with you know the
the West right and you know these boats
arrived and open up Japan as a market
and so on it's famous kind of story and
the Japanese realize they were behind
you know they had been isolated for so
long and you know here were these
Westerners with all of this technology
that you know was like just a level of
magic almost like like a UFO landing
level level thing right um but they were
very pragmatic and very smart and they
said look we're gonna we are going to
change our national slogans right and
you know gosh I'm gonna find a term for
this on there's a there was a yes they
they changed the slogan so it was the
new slogan was enrich the country
strengthen the military but the whole I
want to find the they have different
slogans for different eras see if I
could find it it was it's sort of like a
mission statement but for the country
right I think it was something like
expelled to barbarians and Revere the
Emperor right and and then and then the
new one was like enriched I'm probably
butchering this but the new one was
enrich the country strengthen military
so point being that going from expel the
barbarians and Revere the Emperor to you
know enrich the country strengthen the
military that's that's actually very
different right the first is um you know
a slogan which is about status right
expelled a barbarians revered the
Emperor right and the second is a slogan
which is about growth right
you know enrich the country you know
strengthen the military and that's
that's a radical
actually right it's a change in mission
statement and so and so Japan modernized
and they became you know that's why they
you know they're the first you know
non-white country to actually be a
European power that was actually a very
big deal the russo-japanese war in the
early 1900's right which is the first
time that a non-white country had beaten
a white country you know you know or
European majority however you want to
call it in a war and it was a huge thing
for like colonialism - it was one of the
big things that helped colonize people
realize they could win right and I'd you
know like that gets to all kinds of
historical stuff but my main point on
this was uh whether it was sathya
turning around microsoft whether it was
yeltsin looking and seeing how behind
russia was whether it was the japanese
going and doing the meiji you know
restoration um this was something where
folks who were smart realized they were
behind and rather than get all outraged
about someone pointing that out
they're like okay we're behind how do we
get ahead right and this actually brings
us to china which is you know 1978 when
Deng Xiaoping you know took over China
it was very difficult by the way for him
to take over China that's a whole story
most Americans it's it's actually kind
of interesting to me um you know this
this is actually one of the more
important things to know like how to
china become rich right how did india
become rich just like you'd read a
Harvard Business School case study on on
Netflix right or Amazon how did these
countries turn around you agree about
how companies turn how do you turn on a
country that's even harder right many
much harder um and I think there's a lot
of lessons for business and management
and so on
even if again you know like I'm sure the
comments oh my god China is evil okay
got it right fine
III may agree with you on on many of
these premises um just like you know the
Soviet Union was evil in many ways and
yet we can discuss it in a dispassionate
way that you know like they did do
Sputnik right and that was something
that helped
put out the space race and so on and so
you know we can kind of separate those
two bits right okay coming back to ding
shopping for a second he also turned
around the country right so it's a
fourth example of these turnarounds
right so Thea turning around Microsoft
you know Russia at least partially
turning themselves around I mean they
had a horrible go of it in the 90s with
the transition to capitalism but a
former Soviet Union countries like I
Sonya did extremely well Poland has done
well and so and so on net it's probably
you're not probably it is a win and
certainly Japan did well okay so how did
how did ding Jia ping turnaround China
well he had a few things which have
become slogans now you know the famous
one you know black cat white cat doesn't
matter if it catches mice another one
was let some people get rich first which
basically said look I know that we're
gonna go from everybody equally poor to
some degree of quote you know income and
wealth inequality but that's okay so
long as you realize you'll get you know
wealthier later and these are very
compact slogans right let's um get rich
first doesn't mean you'll never get rich
it just says by been injecting the word
first it's like okay fine they go first
I'll go second but it's fine right um
later there's another slogan that the
Chinese have which is the backwards will
be beaten okay that's very important
where you know there's a this guy called
scholars I think scholar staged on
Twitter I may be butchering that but um
he has a good article on this but the
backwards will be being basically means
that you know China you know it's a
proud country and during you know the
opium wars and you know during the how
the Japanese invaded them during World
War two you know they were they were
brought low right by folks outside with
superior technology and so China itself
has a balance between rationalism and
nationalism right so and these are an
intention okay so nationalism is you
know like be proud China is the best you
know etc and rational them says hey we
may not be the best in something what
are we not the best in let's learn about
that those are in tension
game and you know when you combine them
you have something where you can both
advance science and you know strengthen
the military and the country and so on
and so forth you know another place that
rationalism and nationals are in tension
that you're actually very familiar with
where crypto because every crypto tribe
there's the nationalism of boosting my
coin and there's the rationalism of the
technology and the science and the
features of other coins that might be
worth adopting we're thinking about or
looking at you know obvious example
being let's say privacy right you know
anybody in in a Bitcoin should know
about Z cash and zero knowledge and
that's that's just important right that
makes Bitcoin better right and um if if
you're in the mode of oh everything's
ship going or whatever you know that's
just excessive nationalism right and not
enough rationalism now with that said
something I have learned over the last
six seven years is there's more value to
nationalism than you might think you
know because you can the the tribalism
of crypto is in a sense an extension of
Mac versus PC or you know Emacs versus
VI there's something about it where it's
not just a technology but a community
and it's a sunk cost and there's
something where a community
gains value from expanding because if
you have a billion people using iOS it's
better for you as an iOS user than if
there's only a million people right
which is kind of why this technology
evangelism takes place on a I'm not
saying it's like always that quote
self-interested or whatever but it's
it's I think it's one of the reasons
right and that reaches its apotheosis or
maybe not maybe it's not yet maybe
there's there's more forms yet right
with with crypto where there's a
financial incentive to bring other
people into your coin etc right so that
that irrational nationalism is actually
helpful to fight off price drops right
say this is the
I don't care what it says on the screen
I don't care what you say couldn't close
my ears never gonna sell cetera it's
actually kind of good to have some of
those folks in the community but not too
many because there's too many then you
can't improve or react to anything
you'll never admit flaws of any kind
right so uh all right let me pause there
because that's that's a lot of history a
lot of stuff yeah so I want to go back
to the China thing in a second but
staying on this nationalism versus
rationalism it sounds like what you're
saying is if you have nationalism
without the rationalism it's almost like
everyone feels like hey we're in this
together but we're all the poor people
in China back in the day right like
there's no ability to actually improve
or change or recognize what needs to be
done it's just you're all bought into
this blind belief yeah it gets even
worse than that though because um it
turns into there's no growth right the
rationals is what provides a growth the
Nationals is what provides a tribalism
and in the absence of any growth people
fight over a zero-sum pie because it
doesn't just stay as nationalism it
becomes nationalist socialism where you
know right like like those tribes you
know one way of putting it is you know
you see this dynamic on Twitter whatever
ideology somebody may claim to have on
Twitter it becomes Twitter ism where the
most extreme version of that ideology is
selected for likes and cliques and so on
and the folks who promulgate that are
reinforced in that by other people's
social reinforcement and it just like is
this feedback loop that is kind of a
radicalizing sort of thing right this is
all the time no matter what your ayala
is if it's whether it's tolerance well
you get fu right whether it's a
non-aggression principle it ends in fu
right these things well that's
interesting non aggression is fu now of
course people say oh well that's just
violence or every but actually means
civilization as well you know like you
know there's there's a the point of the
non-aggression principle is not to go
around saying fu to everybody the point
is to maintain a civilized society
and you know like it's it's something
where like civilization is good even if
people take it for granted right and so
so gosh I lost my try thought so let's
keep going down that path of how does
that apply to China which I think okay
well let me finish before I just
remember go ahead so so the thing is
that um all these ideologies become
Twitter ISM and Twitter ISM become
zero-sum because once you have try
ballistically managed to shoo off
everybody show off all growth sure if
anybody that wants to improve it and so
on then you fight among other people for
who is the most tolerant of them all who
is the maximalist of the maxilla you
know like this this kind of stupid thing
right like in this in this very closed
loop of people where you try and find
some flaw that this person had and then
just attack them right you know and and
that's actually the trap that you know
China was certainly stuck in for many
many years right purge after purge after
purge internal political rivalries and
so on and so forth so so you get
tribalism without the growth mentality
and then you know the flip side of it is
you can also have excessive rationalism
right
excessive rationalism I think is less
pathological than excessive nationalism
but it basically results in you having
you know a bunch of science and a bunch
of engineering and a bunch of cool stuff
but you know somebody will come and take
away all your toys it's like it's like
in Civilization you know the ear play
the game of course yeah so civilization
the game if you put all your money into
technology in commerce and and nothing
else the guy next door were the one
Spearman can just come in and take all
your stuff right so if you if you go
excessively rationalist you do not
survive either right so so clearly
there's some kind of balance here and I
think that that
trade-off is something that we're going
to need to negotiate as a society
because it's a real adaptation and
unfortunately feel we're moving in the
wrong direction on it where people are
becoming more irrationally nationalistic
just at a time when it's actually more
important to be open-minded yeah so on
this piece I guess part of this is is
that balance where we talk about
negotiating the balance is that driven
from the state level or is that
something that's more bottoms-up and
driven by the people and who they elect
into office and kind of the people
actually end up controlling that and in
some way it's it's all the above I mean
in a sense of you know the state just as
one example right World War two the the
state had women go off to war and not to
actually fight but to like they were
working in factories and so on and then
afterwards there was a new normal and
women were working more more frequently
right so something where a centralized
thing came in from above changed
behavior and preferences and then even
when that force was removed there was
still a permanent Delta right there's
still a change so soon were top-down and
bottom-up like you know even when
top-down left bottom-up retains some
imprint of the top-down force and then
kind of went on its own right and so so
I don't think it's you know it's just
one example like you know tariffs matter
right like you know the the trade policy
really matters immigration policy
matters those are things that are set
you know somewhat top-down and just say
some was obviously outcry matters and so
on as well but uh you know those
definitely influence what is feasible
bottom-up right so I wouldn't I wouldn't
be able to divide it necessarily but
what I would say is certainly in if you
feel you're in a technology space right
um it behooves you to look at every
green zone that's out there and
understand what they're doing right and
then also think through okay what's
going to happen in red zones
and so just let me define terminology
here because I'm just using it for my
Twitter a river but a green zone is
basically a place that's gotten the
virus under control and in you know you
can be more precise and say it's a it's
a region with comprehensive testing that
has no new cases in let's say you know
two weeks or four weeks right some time
period and the reason both those are
important comp region so it's a spatial
region with comprehensive testing so
because if you're not testing then I
don't believe you're a green zone right
and no new cases meaning you have
extended a streak right you're being
just sampling I'm gonna have you and and
you really have called a virus right
okay and a red zone is everywhere else
right both the places without testing
because you don't know if the virus is
there and certain the place that I've
testing and that IV let it go vertical
so one of my PCs is that green zones
will actually in general be able to sort
of let up on the the state will be there
but in general they're gonna have better
health better wealth and less of a state
presence okay the reason being because
you've sort of managed to keep society
like lick wobbling on a new normal right
rather than just have it crash right
conversely in a red zone I think you're
going to get huge strain pressures on
where you get a series of things where
viral destruction leads to economic
disruption leads to viral destruction
leads to like did they actually you know
stack on top of each other right so for
example right you have the serious virus
okay then folks you know they do
lockdown or in you know a cargo cult
lockdown
okay then they all get mad
understandably because people are going
bankrupt and so on they come out and
some of them unfortunately are like oh
the virus isn't a big deal or you know
just the flu bro or whatever right don't
wear masks boom that leads to another
level of viral destruction right Oh
actually yeah I mean I kill you but it
might significally diminish lung
function for the rest of your life or
for weeks or months who knows right and
who knows the percentage on that yeah we
don't have good
bidadi stats we have good mortality
stats or I should say okay mortality
stats like we know case fatality rate
and and so on we don't yet know like
what percentage of normal people you
know have eight week convalescence 'iz
or permanently decreased lung function
we don't know the long-term effects of
this thing all right so so folks who
just rushed out there oh oh actually BAM
they just walk right into this virus
which is going crazy by the way in 50
states uh and then then that leads to
yet another pullback where demand goes
back and you know like people go back at
home and so on and at least some more
unemployment and more unhappy people and
and that kind of stuff stacks now you
don't have the money to go and pay for
you know like masks or hand sanitizer so
people get the virus more you know that
that type of stuff right so you can have
this really negative feedback loop
actually not a negative feedback loop
it's a positive feedback loop in a sense
of amplifying it right on that leads to
[Music]
more unrest potentially and you know so
Iran actually had some civil unrest and
whatnot right
um and I mean the biggest thing is
Americans should understand that it can
happen here I mean it just as one
example Michigan evidently are do you
see this thing I did see it and I think
that uh actually Michigan was real guns
and I don't know if you saw Raleigh
North Carolina where I grew up there was
people who walked around with fake guns
so they literally took like a piece of
wood and made it look like a 50 caliber
they had an inner tube that they made
look like an 84 you know rocket launcher
and they were basically doing a play on
Michigan was real we're pissed off we're
not gonna go walk around with the 84 for
real but like here's our almost social
unrest display and it's just very
interesting to see that happening in
locations exactly and so I mean look
it's this whole situation is bad on like
a number of different levels but it's
it's something where you're getting more
sci-fi
movie almost every day right and the
problem is that you know there's at
least two analogies for what the virus
is doing and the littles talked about
some of the crypto implications of it
one analogy is to analogize it to an
invasion okay so people have talked
about this they're like oh is this a
recession or a depression and that's
because um you know those are the things
that come to mind as is this like the
2008 crisis or not because everybody
lived through that it's a reference
point right um but I think that a better
analogy I mean this is not fundamentally
an economic event it's not fundamentally
a political event it's it's a biological
event it's a physical event right and
it's like imagine this thing floating in
space and then you project it down into
the XY plane okay it's basically red Dom
interviewers on the movie right they
look out the window and also they're
getting invading people parachuting into
the the parking lot right that's it it's
not biological incident that's exactly I
think it's so with the very very
important caveat it's just because I
know some of the little mystery odors
I'm not saying it's a bio weapon or
anything like that okay I'm not okay
it's a naturally occurring virus
probably with everything we know it's
possible it could have escaped from the
lab whatever people have talked about
that I think that's it's a possibility
but um you know like there's no evidence
indicates a bioweapon okay with that
said the entire US military and NATO
were basically imaginal I'm Joan that is
right yeah so good yep well so you know
in France after World War one they're
like oh we're gonna build a system of
fortification so the next time the
Germans come with their trench warfare
we'll be ready for them and the Germans
just completely invalidated that where
the Nazi blitzkrieg just went around you
know and it was like a classic example
of fighting the last war and then the
French just got defeated right and you
know the US military and NATO have been
m.i.a
in the pandemic right and by the way you
know people say oh you know Asia had
SARS and they were ready and we weren't
like the u.s. had an anthrax scare in
2001 right number one number two is you
know there was a bola in 2014 right and
number three there were actually written
pandemic plans like Bush had something
on this look you know DARPA stuff
there's all the stuff that's written
down it's supposed to be like a bio
defense program or whatever it just they
can't execute on it right they're
literally incapable of doing it so the
every rogue state every terrorist
frankly every state in the world has
seen that you know all the defenses of
the u.s. right you know you have the
Atlantic in the Pacific you have all
these aircraft carriers and nuclear
missiles and so on all the soldiers
everything basically just completely
invalidated by the virus well here's one
kind of analogy that I've thought
through so that I don't know if you
noticed I was in the Army for a six and
a half years and so oh really okay
relatively intimate with both the
expertise and the incompetence that goes
on within those work just like any
organization I'm not beating up on the
military but I'm just saying that just
yeah go ahead yeah well so here's one
way to think about this right is a one
of the most successful ways to attack
the US military over the last decade or
so has been actually to either use
embedded soldiers so like in Afghanistan
for example US and Afghan soldiers go
out on a mission all of a sudden the
Afghan soldiers which are deemed
friendly
turn and shoot a us right right you can
kind of a a blue on blue type incident
but yes they have a different uniform
they're just around the second thing
would be something like a Fort Hood
shooting where literally is somebody in
a US unifies yeah this radicalized shoes
yeah then if you go to what aircraft
carrier where I think it was a general
or Colonel or whatever right so the
virus extends that because you basically
are capturing somebody and turning a
soldier into a threat by basically yeah
and so we saw this on and kind of
steroids if earlier just a couple of
weeks ago there was a I'll call him the
captain of the ship I don't remember
exactly Rozier yeah literally said look
I'm basically stuck on an aircraft
carrier with a bunch of soldiers and
every single one of them is now a weapon
against each other because they're just
infecting each other and I don't have
the tools to handle this right basically
let me be
home not ready for me let me actually
cut he's stabilizing my ship so that I
can protect my soldiers and we can
preserve our readiness in the future and
I think that that is something just
people didn't understand people didn't
think about and when then when you see
it happened you're like whoa that could
decimate an entire military force it
could decimate a lot of different folks
our friendship a French aircraft carrier
got taken down right and you know like
basically there's there's a sense I mean
you know World War one started with
cavalry do you know that right look I
actually you're an army guy you know
more military history than I do for sure
but um a lot of people don't know this
it that's actually you know it started
with horses and horse charges and ended
with you know the first mechanized
warfare right uh I have a feeling that
you know khava 19 may make the era of
infantry and even human staffed you know
boats and so on go away and it'll just
all be a robot war it's all drones all
drone ships all drone everything and it
won't be human staff go ahead yeah and I
think part of this this fits into the
larger narrative just like the virus has
just served as an accelerant right and
I'm you know if you would talk to people
a year ago and said hey in the future
are we gonna have more foot soldiers or
more drums right on the battlefield
most people would say hey it's gonna get
more automated it's gonna get more kind
of autonomous evolved right now all of a
sudden it becomes well not only is that
technology one component of it but we
actually may be rendered not as
effective if there's things like this
out there right I mean you know in any
sort of military unit that spends lots
of time together that's like the exact
opposite thing you want to be doing for
you know some sort of viral outbreak
exactly that's right and and especially
given you know a few things first is uh
the I mean like it's it's actually a
pretty serious virus for at least some
fraction of healthy people okay we don't
know the exact percentage but you know
for example I posted that thing with
that 45 year old former football player
right or Mara gay in the New York Times
has written about her story right you
know Kat Gleason it's not for a very fit
Elissa chef in ski
you know Lauren Sugarman like these are
folks who you know they've all tweeted
about it and what have you
there's plenty more who you know I can't
even talk about but I've I've talked to
a lot of kaabah 19 patients because you
know in tech you know there's a saying
right you look at your dashboards and
you talk to customers right there's a
quantitative and a qualitative and and
you know it's people will often I think
have a middlebrow dismissal of talking
to customers or talking patient's okay
oh that's anecdotal that's you know N
equals one oh you know blah blah and
what they don't understand is every data
collection starts or not every many data
collection efforts start with a
conversation like that for example
you're looking at your dashboards and
you talk to a customer and they say oh I
was able to log in you're like oh no
really
and then you go and you instrument that
and you find 10 percent of your
customers can't log in on mobile safari
or whatever right and you're like I oh
my god yeah you're just blind to that
you were data blind because you didn't
have the metric and you have the metric
cuz you hadn't talked to customers right
the analog of that today is folks who
are looking at lethality stats case
fatality rates and they're seeing
correctly and this is important 92% of
deaths are for people over age 50 and 75
percent of hospitalizations are for
people over age 50 and I have to quote
of those you know stats a lot and it's
important to know those things but the
wrong conclusion is okay then that means
you know I'm 30 so I've got nothing to
worry about right yeah you may not die
right that's true but and so relative to
death everything is mild okay however um
relative to a cup of coffee in person
you may not want to risk you know a
10-week sickness and permanently
decrease lung function right so so like
it's where you set that bar and the
problem is people are comparing it to
the death and they're thinking oh it's
not a big deal of course short you know
few things or big deal relative death
right go ahead you're gonna say well I'm
just going to ask so part of this I
think in the thing that I personally
struggle with the most and I think other
people that I talk with there's this
element of like
accurate is the data right and I'm sure
you got the whole conversation with I
don't think it is a fair question or a
fair expectation to have a hundred
percent accuracy in the data in the
middle of kind of the firestorm right
it's kind of like you're at war and if
you said to somebody how many bullets
you got left maybe somebody knows but
most people say well I got less than I
had when I started right and ignited
directionally and so I think that for
this how I can give you a good answer I
can give you my answer on that okay so I
understand like how important you think
like exact accuracy versus directional
extra extra accuracy is during this yeah
so so um I mean it does to pen you know
if you're talking about the dosing of a
drug sometimes you know like it actually
can be sensitive right but um yeah in
general I you know I I think directional
is a way to go because we're in kind of
fog of war kind of situation with that
said there's some very high signal
events right wuhan happened Italy
happened NYC happened right like these
are well documented you know they're
like basically you know in late January
and early February when I was fighting
off the first just the flu folks right I
would basically make the following point
which was December first wuhan was
normal City by January 23rd hospitals
were overflowing and the city was shut
down by the Chinese government like you
know you had like uh you you basically
had the thing brought to a halt right
like the sickness brought the city to a
halt that's not like a flu situation
right the same thing what's that 53 days
yeah exactly 53 is less than two months
you had a city basically brought to its
knees right and um you know that is that
was that's not that is simply I mean
every every single person in that city
you there been the flu coming through
before right so the flu thing by the way
is it's one of these mind viruses that I
think will end up killing or what it
does is it increases the number of
people killed by Corona because it
disables the behavioral immune system
it's kind of like you know this thing
has a stealth mode to it where because
the symptoms it produces our variable
not everybody melts down in a pool of
blood like Ebola right like Ebola ones
like okay that's gonna kill me and you
take extreme precaution on it right you
know or or like you know something like
9/11 right like it was very obvious that
things got blown up is very visible
right is very tangible this is invisible
and it's highly variable and you're
basing everything I mean you're not
getting close to a corona patient right
you know probably right you're at least
not intentionally so everything is like
at a distance and what I've realized is
that if you don't trust you know experts
or the press and you know what there's
unfortunately a lot of good reasons not
to trust them because they've messed up
a lot yet on their hand they're not you
know even if they I mean this is you
know I tweeted this our day but
basically expert I mean it's so obvious
right but I'll just say this like you
know Democrats need to learn that
experts aren't always right Republicans
need to learn that experts are always
wrong libertarians need to learn that a
state can succeed and progressives need
to learn that a state can fail and those
are all like almost tautologically
obvious kind of things yet I think it
given some of the responses to that they
poked sir directly at a few blind spots
there right because once you move from
the menisci and ideological 0 or 100
aspect right um you say yeah ok CDC did
screw up WH or describe but they don't
they're not everything they publish is
wrong you have to be able to read it
critically and then that now here's the
rub the rub is most people cannot do
technical diligence if they can't do
technical diligence they can only do
social diligence and so they can only
like trust something uncritically or say
it's all fake so what's happened is
because our Institute and and so one of
the issues also is just as our
institutions have become more noticeably
unreliable
they've dumped their chest harder to say
how how they are the truth great example
the New York Times literally runs an ad
campaign about how it's the truth when
it published a bunch of bad reporting on
Corona early on like including things
that said oh it's all xenophobic and
what-have-you right and and then you
know like it actually had some justice
food journalism in there and then you
know two months rumors they were saying
it's not just the flu well who would
have given them that idea right you know
like Fox did and Rico did and and
BuzzFeed did and wash those perspectives
did and wire did and and so on who would
have given that idea right and so the
the issue is that there'll be a real
tragedy which is folks who reasonably do
not trust these institutions will find
that they're not always wrong so and
yeah and then press on this component
right because you get into like the
people in Michigan who show up it with
you know with guns and right we're
basically saying look we don't want to
agree to the lockdown and and there's
this underlying sentiment in the United
States specifically around freedom the
Constitution just don't tell me sure do
right and that to me kind of feels like
it bleeds into this idea of the
countries that are the government's
they're they're not always wrong but
there is a some you know sense of
distrust or if everything goes to [ __ ]
I'm gonna take my personal freedom and I
can you know go solve my own problem and
I think you're seeing some of the
extreme examples of that when people
show up in Michigan etc but at what
point do we get where that becomes not
the extreme and starts to seep into the
maing mainstream mentality and it leads
to the ultimate failure of an
institution right or actually it's not
just a w-h-o being wrong sometimes
people just point and say they're always
wrong we no longer trust them
unfortunately it's already there we're
like this q and on stuff and you know
play endemic and what have you I mean
that's some true crazy stuff right and
and you know it's not even
it's it's no longer rational it's like
arguing with like a religion or
something because folks they don't they
don't they're not arguing in the way
that I would talk to a scientist which
is here's X here's Y if a then B you
know that kind of thing
they're just there Shawn another planet
right and the the problem is people
people don't understand how much stuff
is running like you know to just keep
society going right and if you if you
break all of that you're taking it for
granted right these armed protesters and
so on like look I understand that
they're quote mad about the lockdowns
and so it I think that they're not
really but let's talk about that just
for a second okay just because it's it's
being turned too spidery thing and it's
much more complicated that okay first
the best outcome would be like a New
Zealand or Australia or Taiwan you know
which is a democratic country that
managed to control the virus that's
gonna have healthier people and
wealthier people in the long run okay so
it shows that a it's possible B is
achievable and C is achievable without
becoming a police state and so on very
very important to know that that was
possible okay all right said that that
was possible but the u.s. hasn't
achieved it so what does that mean okay
so when you've got an out-of-control
virus and it's a serious virus okay so
let's take that as a premise because
folks want to there's the folks who want
to say it's like just the flu or
whatever leave that aside for now okay
you've gotten out of control serious
virus that means so if we give the
analogy of an invasion right I'm gonna
give a different analogy which is the
power going out okay so our society is
explicitly premise on power water roads
and increasingly internet right and if
the power goes out you don't expect
restaurant to be able to serve the same
number of customers Alban doesn't work
for example the lights don't go on you
know all the type of stuff right okay if
the water goes out you don't expect them
to serve customers you expect the you
know state the utility to fix that and
then if it can't you realize okay I need
to get a generator I need to get like a
water purifier and those by the way are
inefficient you know when they're not
done centrally a lot of the stuff is
much much much more efficient when it's
done centrally from a power standpoint
from a cost standpoint having 10,000
generators is just you know those things
aren't as good right
solar panels are different I can come
back to that but let's say in general
okay plus a pain in the neck right it's
something where it's a tax not just on
your money but it's on your time to like
not be able to plug something in and
have it go on okay so these are
utilities that were explicitly premise
Don but we are implicitly premise on the
absence of serious infectious disease in
the public square okay I want to linger
on this point we are taking or we until
Kaba 19 took for granted the public
health triumphs of the 20th century so I
tweeted this you know but basically
there's a review from 1976 of the
conquest of infectious diseases like a
Bicentennial summary right I talked
about all the measures and chucking an
enormous it was it was thought of at
that time in 1976 as a massive social
and technological achievement on par
with like getting to the moon was
controlling you know cholera malaria
tuberculosis all these infectious
diseases in the United States and and
this is before they had PCR I didn't
have PCR testing didn't have much of the
technology we have today they did a lot
of it with you know training of swamps
and you know like sanitation certainly
vaccines and whatnot but basically they
took the problem seriously and they
executed on and they went and eradicated
or controlled a lot of these diseases
and what's happened is over the last 50
years people have just sort of forgotten
that that was ever a thing
and so that's how we have society or
many many businesses our premise on the
presence of this utility which is public
health
for example conferences or concerts or
you know frankly any large crowd of any
kind rallies right or public public
transit you know restaurants bars all of
these things with gatherings of large
crowds are implicitly premise on the
public health being being present so
like the power going out you can think
of the health have going out so what
happens if the health is gone out just
like it would be kind of crazy to say to
a restaurant power through and just
serve your customers if the oven doesn't
work well if the health has gone out and
the restaurant opens back up a bunch of
things happen first some significant
fraction of customers stay home second
there's new costs that are imposed on
the restaurant and if you saw
California's reopening guidelines for
restaurants but they basically expect
like Joe's diner to implement bio
defense mode okay all right so if Josiah
nerd go ahead I was gonna say that
sounds very reasonable right yeah
exactly it's the state is failed so it's
a Snow Crash thing alright so so number
one many customers will stay home right
number two new costs are imposed on a
place which is at its lowest point
financially it's just been two months
out of revenue it's it's like sucking
sucking wind
businesses down and now the state
expects it to like you know basically
build a clean room around a dining table
right okay number three workers will get
sick the virus is uncontrolled right so
you have much more in the way of random
matches number four you have PR and
liability risk the moment that like your
restaurant or whatever is marked a
hotspot because you know there's a
report a news report of someone getting
it boom business vanishes again right to
show that that's not an exaggeration in
South Korea 2,000 bars were shut down
after one guy you know walk through five
do you see that
I do not okay yeah so after South Korea
opened up okay because they've gone the
virus under control one cob at 19 guy
walked into a bar and and he went into a
few bar hopped for a night and managed
to in fact like all in the order of 40
to 70 people the exact numbers still
being determined nineteen hundred people
had to be test and traced and two
thousand bars were shut down one guy one
guy yep one guy right now I'm like I'm
not seeing it's his fault or anything
like that he didn't know I think he was
asymptomatic or a bit happy right but um
this gives a sense of how the when the
health has gone out a significant part
of the economy is no longer economically
feasible to the same extent right
anything based on you go ahead so so and
and the lockdown doesn't doesn't fix it
is my point right unless you control the
virus you have less customers two people
will social distance you have like bio
defense mode that you need to implement
if you don't implement it then workers
will get sick and people who come will
get sick and there's constant PR and
liability risk so what do I think
actually happens right I think happens
is many restaurants um will essentially
just take restaurants for a second I'll
go to other kinds of businesses they
will have to upload themselves and
clarify themselves what I mean by that
so the restaurant will shut down it's
the smart restaurant will shut down its
physical facility sighting force majeure
do cloud kitchens calm to set up a new
back end which is headless and that can
be by the way out in the middle of
nowhere it doesn't have to be a plumb
location you don't need you don't care
about your tables you don't care about
your chairs your decor number three your
storefront becomes purely digital you're
in an app and number four you basically
are now just delivery only okay so
you've digitized yourself you become
headless you cut off the front right at
the restaurant itself is shut down but
this is another very important aspect
you could end the lockdowns well that
actually takes away leverage from
businesses in an important way
because now it's no longer an atypical
time it's no longer a typical time they
have to pay all their rent and other
kinds of things but now there are 25
percent of revenue right so you've
pushed them into this weird intermediate
state which is also kind of likely to
kill them and the the fundamental thing
I think is the end of the lockdowns
folks look III understand I understand
where they're coming from a lot of folks
I mean I've never been blase if you look
at my feet even even back to early March
when people were talking about shutting
down South by Southwest and so on
right um it almost made me like throw up
to think about okay you know these
people work so hard on this for a whole
year I know how hard it is to organize
something and then people say oh just
shut down your conference well that's
good you know that's that's something
where those guys are just taking it on
the chin for a public good you know
maybe the state could reimburse them or
something I was thinking you know but
now it's so widespread you multiply that
by a million that's what's happened in
America right so I totally understand
where the end lockdowns folks are coming
from the issue is that even though you
might risk it for to go back to work for
your job you're not gonna risk it to um
just go and like get a drink at the bar
or if you do you may not you may not do
so forever right so let's talk mmt BTC
right you know it's funny I last year or
for a while I've basically be talking
about how the title fight of the 2020s
will be mmt versus BTC and I think
that's coming even faster than I
expected
we're we're definitely you know whether
you call it mm tea or not we are
definitely in the time of the unlimited
government right and you know that's the
opposite by the way of limited
government its unlimited government so
you have a government that has no limits
on you know it can put people under
house arrest effectively with lockdowns
it can change prices it can you know
shut down your business it can ban
flights it can print money it's
basically a wartime kind of government
right the unlimited government and the
thing about mmt is it doesn't make any
sense in my view if you like in in in
logic
terms okay and just to articulate what
it is for those folks who don't know
what it is modern monetary theory or mmt
is there's there's the observation that
the state can print money and that's
often accompanied by the recommendation
that the state should print money okay
and it should print money to pay for
everything and that there's no
constraint on the state doing this right
and you know essentially like if they're
pressed on oh won't to cause inflation
they say well don't worry if inflation
happens and prices start going up we'll
just raise taxes to pull the money we
just printed back out of the economy
right now the the just to show that I'm
not making this up there's a there's a
video that you might be able to link or
what have you by a gosh it's I I tweeted
it a while back but it essentially shows
the MMT folks treating the economy is
like a tank of water and they pump in
water and they pull it out with taxes
and so on and this is a very naive view
for many many reasons one of which is in
type of inflation if you try to increase
taxes well people you know they've
already got lower consumption and
they're gonna resist that number two is
the economy is not a tank of water it's
it's adversarial right like people will
respond to incentives and one of the
things they'll do is they'll move their
money into BTC or to other
cryptocurrencies and so on and get out
of the tank where you know you're you're
printing all this money and so MMT you
know you can't be really understood in
terms of what its people say but it can
be understood from a different sense
which is I have a gun right mmt is the
language of the state the total state
the unlimited state which says ah the
state can increase taxes to 99% and
expropriate everything you have right
because that's what that means like
print all the money means dilute you
down to zero it's like being able to
print trillions of shares on the cap
table or what happy right and so it
means that I can print all this
and because it's currency within this
realm I can see is any asset of anybody
and do so in a quiet and stealth way
right because you don't see your
percentage of you know market cap right
now one thing I want to be clear about
it's not as simple as just straight
inflation because there's huge deflation
occurring in the economy as well so
we're probably gonna get something where
it's like pandemic deflation as I
mentioned of all the all the things
people don't want like concerts go to
zero in terms of price or drop
substantially all the things they do
want rise in price okay so so in one
corners mmt this language of the total
state in their corner is BTC which is um
you know maybe the leader of the free
world
right I think it's a provocative
statement but um you know the u.s.
itself is sort of absent globally from
the pandemic crisis you know it doesn't
stand for freedom it or rather I mean
maybe it does but it's not like you know
usually when there's like a flood in
some country you have Marines land and
they you know hug babies and pose for a
photo op and you know it's good stuff
right you know like that they're moving
sandbags you probably did some of those
missions or whatever um and and the u.s.
is completely absent from the global
stage on this they're not defending
other countries because they've been
invaded themselves right and so who's
the leader of the free world I think
it's gonna be Bitcoin or bitcoin is a
leader of the free world you're kind of
talking about here's MMT is a complete
state initiated process you devalue the
currency you get people addicted to the
state being the savior and having to
drive all of the value and literally
it's like a child and a mother right the
mother has to take care of the child or
the child doesn't make Bitcoin is some
weird way 180-degree difference and it
is coming at it from in one area you can
print as much as you want in this one
you can print zero right it is
completely decentralized two different
and so I think a lot of people are
wondering okay I buy the argument that
those two worlds are going to co-exist
for some period of time can they coexist
wherever or do they meet in kind of that
boxing match in the middle and one has
to knock the other way so I think that
where they sew the analogy I would give
is I think BTC ultimately wins but it's
gonna be a giant fight between I mean
like you know think about Facebook
before 2016 and then Facebook afterwards
afterwards everybody's like oh my god
this thing is actually extremely
powerful and and you know all these
attacks were launched it's still
standing but it took more fire at that
time than it ever had before
once Bitcoin hits a hundred thousand I
don't know when I mean frankly it could
happen in a week from now it could
happen a year from now it could happen
to five years from now or whatever right
but eventually it will once it hits like
a hundred thousand and you know the
current being what it is it could happen
in a day after being nothing for a long
time when it does and I've no doubt that
it will eventually simply because so
much money is being printed when it does
then you're gonna get another level of
state interest in it in all senses of
the term some states will actually adopt
it as like a gold like thing other
states will try to stamp it out you know
but as long as some states adopted and
the internet doesn't go down Bitcoin
will win
you